turning now to a case that's getting
national attention after the supreme
court's decision to overturn roe v wade
this week a 27 year old man named
gierson fuentes was charged with raping
a 10 year old girl in the state of ohio
now that little girl then traveled to
indiana for an abortion because under a
new law in the state of ohio it would
have required her to give birth unless
it was determined her life was in danger
as elaine quijano reports the case is
showing the results of america's new
abortion laws
she indicated that her ten-year-old
daughter was pregnant columbus detective
jeffrey hewn testified in an arraignment
wednesday that 27-year-old gerson
fuentes confessed to raping a
ten-year-old girl at least twice
leading to her pregnancy is that
daughter still pregnant today no why not
the victim went to went out of state to
have a medical
medically terminated
abortion hewn said the victim underwent
the abortion in neighboring indiana at
the end of june
the indiana doctor who said she
performed the abortion said the child
was six weeks and three days pregnant
that's three days longer than ohio
allows an abortion to take place
ohio is one of 11 states with bans that
have no exceptions for rape or incest
that's despite national polling that
says an overwhelming majority of people
support abortions in those conditions
we're gathering the evidence as we speak
indiana's attorney general is promising
to investigate the doctor who performed
the procedure and if she followed proper
reporting protocols we're going to fight
this to the end
including looking at her licensure
if she failed to report in indiana it's
a crime
for to not report to intentionally not
report imagine being that little girl
the case sparked outrage from president
biden last week while he signed an
executive order to protect access to
abortions
10 years old
raped six weeks pregnant already
traumatized was forced to travel to
another state we're going to start to
see a lot more tragic and difficult
cases carrie franklin director of ucla's
center on reproductive health law and
policy said since the nationwide right
to abortion was eliminated by the
supreme court these types of cases will
happen more often in a lot of
anti-abortion states people will find
themselves unable to terminate
pregnancies that are the product of rape
and incest and they will find themselves
in difficult traumatic situations
detective hewn said dna tests are being
conducted to confirm the paternity
fuentes is scheduled to be in court
again next week there has been no
comment from his defense attorney
it's a tough story the columbus dispatch
in ohio which has been covering the
stories you know elaine says that since
may 9 they found this is quoting them up
to 50 incidences police reports filed of
people young women under the age of 15
that have been raped this story really
illustrates just how complex this issue
is how deeply personal this issue is and
you know this is a case that has a lot
of americans reflecting and we're going
to hear i'm sure more about it and 10
years old it's just like ugh it's a
punch of the gut it's an awful lot
horrific it's an extreme case but it
shows the the extremity of the law in
about 11 states no exceptions elaine
thank you very much